If we're going to find a portfolio or an
allocation of assets to different stocks
that minimizes risk, we have to pause
for a moment and consider what is risk.
Let's consider two stocks, XYZ,
here that's gone up about ten percent,
but as you can see,
it's been very volatile.
Here's the historical price
of another stock, ABC.
It also went up ten percent over this
same time period, but as you can see,
it was less volatile.
So it's this volatility that we
use as a measure of risk and
that is simply the standard deviation
of historical daily returns.
Again, in this case,
risk is measured as volatility or
standard deviation of
historical daily returns.
That's the standard view of
risk in most finance texts.
There are other ways to view
risk that we touch upon here and
there through this course but the key
is standard deviation of daily returns.